I think the primary threats to the
current economic recovery would be
retrenchment and fear of moving forward
with the kinds of initiatives and
efforts that were underway before the
economic meltdown yes we need to go
forward with faith and innovation and
sustainability supporting social
entrepreneurship and connecting
governments in ways that they weren't
connected before and be fairly bold and
I actually believe that if we do that we
will have a faster recovery and if we
don't but the inclination is to back off
when you have economic down times and to
go back to what you think was working
and it obviously wasn't or we wouldn't
be here